all right I think we'll go ahead and get
started here good afternoon everybody
and this is usually the the point in
time where everybody starts to fall
asleep so we'll try to have a little bit
of fun with unity and Mathematica to
wake you up with that after after lunch
low my name is George Danner I run a
company in Houston Texas that builds
computer simulations for businesses
we're not in the gaming industry we
don't build games but ineffective we we
do we really sort of do because we build
these simulation models of real-life
corporate examples that we'd like to
have the same sort of quality and
essence if you will of of a good quality
game so we try to mimic some of the
visualization elements that they have so
we've got we've got two things here to
look at you've got Mathematica which is
this amazing technical computing
environment and then you've got unity
which is a very popular game engine it's
used in about 60% of the mobile games
and a very large percentage of both the
desktop and console games and it's an
open source gaming engines very well
engineered
extremely well designed well supported
what happens when you put these two
amazing environments together so we
thought we'd have a little fun by doing
that and in the course of making that
linkage happen perhaps build some
simulation models that that we we just
haven't seen before there is a bit of a
sort of a grander purpose I guess to the
work that I'm doing in visualization I
happen to be writing a book at the
moment the book will be released early
next year available from finer
bookstores by the way shameless plug for
the book but but part of that book is
about problem solving and part of
problem solving as as Conrad mentioned
in his education talk is about the
visualization of
of the problem itself so it's a big
theme in what we're gonna sort of look
at and and and talk about so let's let's
look at these two environments so
Mathematica a course has has great
visualization capability I mean without
question however you do have this game
engine unity that was designed
specifically for very very realistic 3d
visualizations one of my colleagues Alan
Savoy sort of made this quote what if we
could have Mathematica as the writer
using the movie metaphor and unity is
sort of the director in the film studio
in other words could you create logic in
Mathematica about the movement of
objects in a realistic scene and then
come over to unity and watch that scene
play out so last year todd gayly and and
and luke also who was off sailing around
the world now gave a talk about unity
link they built unity link and that was
a direct integration between unity and
Mathematica I thought that was really
neat and and based on their talk
inspired by their talk we did a few
little experiments and we thought well
you know there's something to this whole
idea of blending unity with Mathematica
and it kind of repeats this general
theme that we've had this is our sort of
third talk in a row about integration
which I which I think is an important
and powerful capability of Mathematica
not that it's great in its own right
which it is but the fact that you can
put it together with other unusual tools
and create something even more amazing
so two years ago we talked about the
integration of Mathematica with Google
technologies last year we talked about
integration of Mathematica with Twitter
of all things and and this year it's
unity so some of you may may not really
be
that familiar with with unity so here's
just a kind of a quick well trailer that
I sort of grabbed at random but you know
what you can see is that unity gives you
really kind of the studio if you will
the ability to create these these
amazingly realistic scenes now so notice
you've got some structure there and you
had some clouds the particle system
inside of unity in other words how it
represents so smoke and fire and and
other sort of fluids is again another
really well engineered part of unity and
we actually used it in one of our
applications which I'll show you so I
don't I don't want to do too much of
that that's just okay so game we know
about games we know how wonderful games
are in in in the technical aspects of
them I mean the the the gaming industry
spends hundreds of millions of dollars I
don't know what the figure is but they
spend a lot of money getting the shading
just right getting the colors just right
camera angles lighting all of that so
the nice thing for for us is that we can
take all of that work and build on it
with something like Mathematica so the
question is how can we and should we
link Mathematica in with something like
that so let's let's take a look and
there are a couple of ways when when you
look at all right so I want to integrate
Mathematica with unity how do I do it
there's a really - it comes down to two
different choices now what Todd and Luke
built last year in unity link was
something that very much looks like what
you see here you have you have
Mathematica and then you have much like
J link and our link and and math link
and all of the other sort of connection
technologies built into Mathematica to
allow you to talk to unity and have
unity talk back to you so in other words
it's as if Mathematica was sort of the
puppet master and unity contained the
scenery with all the puppets that
Mathematica could drive it could say
alright move this monster from here to
there or make this particular sword or
weapon
up here so you could have Mathematica
direct the things that are going on in
unity and at the same time you can have
information coming back from unity so
where are certain enemies located in the
scene where are certain things that
objects there so you can get feedback
and you can drive it in real time the
disadvantage that we saw when we looked
at this approach was the whole idea of
deployment you know when we build models
for for companies that want to have
these models you know ultimately they
want it deployed in some way that they
can use them and and deploy deploying
Mathematica together with unity and it's
sort of a tight coupling like that was a
challenge it's something we want to work
on though so what we decided on was
really kind of the architecture option
number two which is on the lower part of
that that page right there which is all
right well let's do it asynchronously
let's have Mathematica generate a script
if you will a script of commands and
these commands are in some protocol that
we sort of dreamed up ourselves and then
have that read into unity and have unity
acted out accordingly it's kind of like
the metaphor of a player piano where you
have the player piano script the little
dots cut out on the page and you flow it
through the player piano and it just
sort of plays it away it's kind of the
way that we did this here for for a
unity it becomes attached actually to
the unity project so he settled on that
and then we said all right what's it
going to take to sort of put that
together the big kind of design aspect
of that was the you know sort of the
structure of the script so it's it's a
it's a list of commands for the actors
so the scene itself is pre-built so we
actually had a studio work with us to
build up sort of scenes and everything
and we asked them also to build sort of
characters and objects for us and then
once you have those in place it's almost
like you have the actors on the stage
then you
give the actors a series of time-based
commands to make them move around on the
stage and in the way that you want them
to move around so we we built some some
code and and incidentally the the code
is you know it's it's it's a lot of
fairly big functions I'm not going to
obviously go into a lot of this code but
it took a lot of code essentially to
generate the script that looks like that
right there so for example here's at
time 55 I'm asking an object called helo
box 3 to move to a destination called
helo target 4 that's another thing that
we we sort of wanted to do with this
script is give it minimal information in
other words in Mathematica you don't
have to know anything really about the
object and how it's supposed to move
from A to B you just tell it go move
from A to B then unity figures that out
or should figure that out in that way
where I think we're taking advantage of
the the power of each environment
Mathematica is very good at sort of
generating these scripts numerically and
you unity is very good at sort of
portraying out the visualization so
that's just kind of a code fragment that
I'm showing you here at some some time
55 whatever that means in the time
pacing here I'm asking an object to move
to a particular location
I'm also updating some data in in unity
I'm saying there's this metric called
compliance and I wanted to have this
certain value at that same time period
55 so it's kind of a structured list of
commands and unity is going to be
processing all this and notice kind of
an interesting thing over here I'm
actually sending it a little piece of
graphic a little spark line if you will
portrayal so we're also in the commands
were actually having unity display a
graph now here was here was something
that sort of if you will violated our
minimal
approach because it turns out that unity
is really terrible at drawing graphs and
you can you can buy code modules in in
the unity store that do certain things
but all the graphing ones were awful
so Mathematica is great at drawing
graphs so the question is could we have
Mathematica draw the graph and just send
the image over to unity so a lot of a
lot of the work that we did was sort of
figuring all of that out and ultimately
building a JSON file that that then
unity can can read I mean JSON is a
native format JSON need a format for
Mathematica it also happens to be a
native format for unity so there was
where we found some sort of common
ground between the two we constructed
the list of commands first and then
reformatted that into a JSON file that
then unity could directly consume and we
had to write a lot of code to kind of
glue those parts together but ultimately
it it worked fine like I said up here
it's it's the embedded graphics that
that were probably the biggest challenge
because we had to figure out how to
break those down basically into text and
what's what's called dehydrating a
graphics image and then rehydrating it
in other words rebuilding the graphic on
the other side in unity that was a that
was a tricky part to this whole thing
okay so alright so what did we do with
this so let's talk a little bit about
the animations that we built and I'll
show you the animations here in just a
minute the first one was offshore
logistics we were approached by a really
large oil company that wanted to drill
for oil in West Africa and in order to
do that you have to have an army almost
literally an army of ships and
helicopters moving personnel and moving
equipment and materials back and forth
from the shore out on the ocean to
these various drilling rigs and the
exact timing of when these boats arrive
and when the helicopters arrive is sort
of an intricate and very complex dance
that's very expensive by the way if you
could figure out a way to optimize those
routes and take say one boat out of the
system or one helicopter out of the
system each one of these these vessels
these work boats offshore rent for fifty
five thousand dollars per day so you can
just do the math on that and it's it's a
lot of money so a lot of our work was
trying to figure out exactly the cadence
of these deliveries for the boat so
let's let's take a look at what that's
like
so here is our unity portrayal I'll back
up just a little bit let's see I can't
see on the right-hand side let's see let
me make it smaller so we can see okay we
can see a little bit better now alright
so the scene and that's actually the
Angolan coastline over there was built
for us and these these drilling rigs
were built for us as well these objects
and now again what we're doing is you
see them flying around in the air what
we're doing is we're directing the boats
to go to certain places weirder Ekta
helicopters to go to certain places so
this is all driven by Mathematica in
other words the game is there and it's
just waiting for these Mathematica
commands like the structure that I just
showed you to come through to say
alright move this helicopter here move
this boat there and we're keeping track
over here on the right hand side
remember the spark lines so these are
the spark lines that are being sent over
from Mathematica to unity to then
display on the heads-up display this is
another wonderful aspect of game engines
as they had you can overlay these
heads-up displays and show all kinds of
metrics about what's going on so you can
even back off the screen a little bit
and whoohoo go into the water and and
see above and scoot around it's uh Minh
and you can see you know my
but pro here is it's a reasonably good
machine but you can see how nicely and
quickly it renders unity renders very
very efficiently there's no there's no
sort of hiccups or anything to the to
the screen as I'm sort of moving around
this scene so that's that's that's one
assignment that we had was to simply
build this and it's interesting we
started showing the people the oil
company based in London by the way you
know kind of this this portrayal of the
scene they said oh that's interesting
for a simulation model but could you
hook that up to a real-time sort of
display so that I could sit in my nice
comfortable office in London and I have
to fly out to Angola and with you know
the heat and the bugs and the dust and
everything and you know that certainly
could be done this could be attached to
a real-time display just as easily so
you're in a sense watching something
that looks very much like a like a
weather you know weather report from
weather bug or something like that
you're watching what's actually
happening instead of a simulated
forecast of what's going on all right so
that's that was one assignment that was
a lot of fun to put together and we were
we were kind of amazed at how quickly we
could put together we built the scene in
about three or four days our studio
built the scene about three or four days
and then we put the interface together
in another sort of week or so so unity
made it easy for us to do this so the
integration wasn't as difficult as we
thought it would be and I think that's
really good news all right the second
the second application that we had was
one of oil and gas drilling a nother oil
company came to us oilfield services
company came to us actually and we're
asking us about this whole
unconventional drilling now you've
probably heard all the press about
fracking hydraulic fracture fracturing
underneath to to drive the oil and gas
particles in the way that you want to
drive them kind of controversial
actually but in essence the
energy industry is really a bit
flummoxed about this whole idea of
unconventional drilling conventional
drilling is you stick up a pipe in a
hole and out comes the oil
unconventional drilling is much more
like mining it's kind of like mining
underground you're you're crushing rock
underground it's very the technologies
are different the geology is different
it's different in every kind of way so
they wanted to really understand
basically how does this viscous fluid
oil and gas and mud and water all mixed
together sort of moving through cracks
in rock so that's when we had a chance
to work with what I think is is a really
powerful part of unity which is the
particle system and I think it probably
lots of applications of the particle
system essentially it allows you to take
some medium that is particulate in
nature so fire or smoke or some kind of
liquid or fog or clouds and and
represent it in a real physics kind of
way inside of unity it's a very kind of
sophisticated and complicated system to
work with but it allows you a whole lot
of flexibility so the challenge for us
was figuring out if in fact we could we
could do this so we created for
ourselves a stimulation source that's
the that blue pipe so imagine that's the
the thing that's injecting this fluid in
there breaking up rocks and then we
created for ourselves an extraction
source so this is pipe that's gonna suck
up the stuff that comes its way so when
we do that we can see that there's the
the gas and oil mixture believe that gas
is the purple and the the oil mixture is
green and still early days and this
we're still playing around with this but
essentially that's the way the stuff is
moving through these rocks we've cut the
rocks away and made them invisible and
we're imagining this fluid sort of
winding its way through this kind of
these capillaries ultim
headed toward the extraction source so
it could be sucked up and they're
testing all kinds of technologies for
making this work and what they wanted to
use was the combination of Mathematica
to do the calculations and then unity to
show how it actually worked so in other
words Mathematica is doing the the
capillary flow calculations we used this
thing called lattice Boltzmann equations
to say alright this piece of fluid is
going to move this way and this piece of
fluid is going to move that way and
wrote up all those calculations
generated another one of these script
files like I was showing you earlier and
it in turn makes the the fluid flow
because the the particle system in unity
is so flexible it allowed us to kind of
program it if you will
to make it move in the way we needed it
to move in color it the way we wanted to
to color it make it as dense as we
needed to make it in order for it to be
an appropriate kind of representation of
a gas and oil mixture so that's that's
Mathematica driving that scene I think
if you had any one tool alone it'd be
really difficult to do something like
this but the fact that you've got the
power of both is is I think I think
really really helpful right so the the
project that we have planned is then to
kind of move into the this more
real-time environment I mentioned
real-time in that a first example so I
think real-time is a real exciting place
to go well it turns out that the British
government makes the position of every
single train in the London Underground
public every 15 seconds so you just go
to a you go to a web service and you
subscribe to that web service and you
can pull down the locations of every
single train as it as it updates so we
thought wouldn't it be cool if we could
build this sort of replica of the entire
London Underground system and you could
sort of swing or
around it like like you were we were
swinging around that other scene and
kind of watched the trains as they sort
of moved from one station to the other
so about 50% of the way there I
unfortunately I didn't have anything to
show you here but that's that's where
we're headed so that we could sort of
just prove that this this real time
aspect can be integrated with again with
Mathematica and unity all together to
give just a hyper realistic view of
what's going on okay so let me let me
just close with a couple of points and
one is you know what did we learn when
we started doing all of this I think you
know there's there's really no question
that that Mathematica was was perfect
for doing this kind of work so those two
applications that I showed you the kind
of marine aviation logistics and the
unconventional drilling those are very
different applications yet we found it
very easy to do the logic inside of
Mathematica even though those were
widely disparate kinds of applications
so we're very big on Mathematica being
the kind of the right platform to do
that kind of work as I mentioned before
unity has some drawbacks in that it's
terrible about at drawing graphs so we
decided to do that in Mathematica and
serve that over to unity we're still
looking at that but I think for the
foreseeable future we'll probably have
Mathematica doing things like time
series graphs what one of my colleagues
went to the Unity user conference this
year in Seattle which is actually just a
couple of months ago and we're learning
about future versions of unity there's a
very active community working on unity
and upgrading and I think the new
version is version 5 that's going to be
coming out it's got some really good
user interface aspects to it and our
overall conclusion is that unity is
going to be an even easier environment
to link Mathematica up to not harder and
and once you do that linkage you're
going to have lots more applications
that we could do and sort of in that
spirit let's let's talk about
some possible applications I mean your
your mind can can go a lot of different
directions when you think about you know
how powerful this this combination of
the two platforms could be I mean one of
the things that I believe could happen
is a lot of medical imaging and medical
reconstruction I mean you'd fly through
a body in and out you could zoom into a
part of the body or take the body and
make it all glass and look at only
certain organs or certain disease
portions of the body a lot of that is
going on right now but what I've
observed and I don't know a whole lot
about medical applications I do know a
little is they use very highly
specialized software to do this and I
think the message here is that we can
use open source software now to do
really sophisticated medical
visualizations the other is and I've
come into contact every now and again
with sports teams that that we work with
and they're very interested in going
kind of beyond Moneyball how many of you
know the Moneyball story or I've seen
the movie or read the book well if you
have it your homework tonight is to go
home and rent that movie or read the
book because it's a it's a great book
about using essentially data science on
sports and and that'sthat's all terrific
you know looking at statistics looking
at the right metrics but going beyond
that and actually replaying certain game
situations in a realistic kind of scene
is going yet beyond Moneyball which is a
really exciting area manufacturing in
logistics is another sort of classic
application of this you could if you
could watch a supply chain or rip the
roof off of a factory and look inside it
and watch a day in the life of it it
gives you a really powerful way to kind
of look at how to improve it large-scale
infrastructure projects we're working
with the Qatari government on the the
soccer world cup in 2022 they've got
lots of big infrastructure ideas about
where to put hotels and soccer stadiums
and the like and working all of that out
we could do that with a lot of that with
unity and and certainly in teaching
almost anything
unity is a great platform so I'll just
kind of move really quickly in on some
of these there's there's those heads-up
displays are going to get a lot more
elaborate we're going to try to crack
the code around this direct architecture
idea do it using unity link and not only
controlling the actors on the stage but
what we'd also like to do is be able to
control the camera picture-in-picture
and swapping the two different you know
thing it's doing things with lighting
like spot putting spotlights on a
particular actor and watching that actor
through the scene and then finally if
you don't know about oculus rift I would
suggest you google it because that's a
sea change in virtual reality virtual
virtual reality headsets were in the
thousands of dollars up until very
recently the latest development kit that
they've released three hundred and fifty
dollars so what that's going to do is
going to bring virtual reality to the
mainstream and by the way unity supports
virtual reality so any of these games
can be done in a sort of a stereoscopic
sort of way and that's that's oculus
rift right there and that's the
stereoscopic scene that you see I so I
think there's lots of really exciting
possibilities when we we put Mathematica
together with other really powerful
things so we're going to just keep going
and see where it leads with that I'll
conclude thank you very much